well alexandria okazi cortez has finally
found a problem with joe biden's
immigration policy no she's not crying
at yet another offense outside an
immigration facility but she's still
pretty upset
she's upset that joe biden is not doing
enough to help ms-13 he's doing a lot to
help but not enough according to sandy
cortez
she was one of 34 house democrats who
sent a letter to the dhs secretary
alejandra mayorkas urging the government
to deport
fewer violent gang members and other
felons
quote we urge the bite administration to
pursue humane and just
immigration policies that aim to end
mass incarceration
criminalization and deportation of
immigrants they went on to suggest
anyone who's against this
is needless to say wait for it a racist
jonathan fahey is the former director of
ice we're happy to have him join us
tonight mr faith thanks so much
for coming on more violent gang members
what
i'm just i hate to ask you a
philosophical question but what could
other than destroying the united states
why would someone before this
other than just simply trying to get as
many illegal aliens in the country as
possible
and to encourage more to come by saying
there's no
no scenario you'll get thrown out i
can't think of anything whatsoever
it clearly will harm public safety and
this is so remarkable because if you
think about it
it wasn't that long ago when democratic
politicians might be on a stage with
police officers or crime victims and
speaking on their behalf
now we have aoc and 34 or so house
members
using their power prestige time
resources to advocate on behalf of ms-13
members it is truly
astonishing and there is no
consideration for the victims of these
gang members because
most of them have probably committed
horrible crimes while they're here
but if we leave them here they'll commit
even more crime and how do you
how do you talk to a crime victim or a
crime victim's family member
and explain to them why we didn't deport
an ms-13 member it is truly
astonishing and this is on the heels of
joe biden's
the policy of what they are now
deporting which is a very timid response
just basically enough to pass a laugh
test you have to meet so many criteria
to get deported
they don't want to they don't want to
deport most criminals
they don't they want to make it hard to
deport any gang members
they support sanctuary cities and then
this
this to say this is not even enough it's
truly astonishing
and people really wonder why we have
this issue at the border
well we we send the message loud and
clear that no matter what you do when
you get here
you will never be deported and when
you're here you get
everything american citizens get and
then some because you clearly have a lot
more representation in congress than
most americans and certainly than crime
victims which is horrible
but you also have more representation in
the white house
and again this is like every single one
of these things the people that bear the
cost of this
the people that live in the
neighborhoods that are afflicted by the
gang members and by the gang crimes that
are intimidated they're terrorized
that their victims most horrible crimes
they're
they're not the ones that are making
these policies they're not the ones that
are going
you know driving whole foods parking
outside their tesla it's it's always
the people that are the forgotten people
that that absorb all of these costs
and it is really you know it's so
harmful it's one of the most cynical and
dishonest
policy debates we've ever had in this
country and you look at this border
crisis where you have
the vice president i don't want to say
her name for fear of mispronouncing it
but
they put her in charge of this one of
the reasons is to really send the
message that anyone
can come here because they put somebody
in charge of the border that
hates law enforcement and is pro-open
borders and pro-embassy so what is the
message to the rest of the world
come on in it's open borders it's
amnesty and if you come in
you're never getting kicked out
and the message is we hate america
kamala harris and ocasio-cortez did not
build this country they couldn't
have they're not capable enough to do
that they hate it and they're trying to
destroy it there's no other explanation
that i can see
you don't have to affirm that but it's
clear to me at this point i appreciate
you coming on jonathan faye thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else